c'est vraiment une rhétorique
typiquement américaine on avait le rêve
américain maintenant on a l'âge d'or qui
est face à nous qui est encore possible
à condition que l'on ne lise Donald
Trump
moi Charlotte
you get again
[Applaudissements]
donc pour cette déclaration de
candidature Donald Trump choisit deux
choses il choisit un moment et un lieu
le moment c'est avant la proclamation
des résultats des élections de mi-mandat
il choisit marre à la gauche chez lui sa
résidence son fièvre après sur la forme
on retrouve tous les grands classiques
de la rhétorique trumpiste d'abord
physiquement on retrouve les petits
souris les mous les doigts pointés
évidemment il va faire huer ces trois
grands ennemis traditionnels
[Applaudissements]
on a Donald Trump assez classique dans
dans ce discours et sur le fond il y a
presque une sorte de rhétorique
sacrificielle c'est à dire que 10 mois
vous savez j'ai pas besoin d'aller à
l'élection présidentielle j'ai une belle
vie vous n'avez pas besoin de ça non
plus et il dit qu'il va par amour donc
il y a quelque chose de sentimental dans
le champ lexical de cette déclaration de
candidature ou Donald Trump parle de lui
[Applaudissements]
on parle toujours de deux choses on
parle d'un programme et d'une personne
un discours politique c'est pourquoi
faire et pourquoi moi quel est mon
programme et pourquoi est-ce que je suis
le plus légitime pour le porter et donc
évidemment Donald Trump commence par
parler de lui et de l'envie et de
l'amour qu'il a pour son pays et qui
partage évidemment avec ses supporters
donc Donald Trump serait le seul à
pouvoir sauver une ultime fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là encore les grands classiques
républicains la peine de mort pour les
trafiquants de drogue la lutte contre la
théorie du genre avec vraiment des
propos très caricaturaux sur les hommes
sont des hommes ce qui flatte totalement
son électorat il ne manque pas cette
occasion de son discours de susciter des
applaudissements c'est ce qu'on appelle
en rhétorique un claptrap quand on cite
un thème dont on sait que il va faire
surgir des applaudissements dans le
public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un peu ce quête à Donald Trump le
Yes We Can de Barack Obama un motif de
ces discours constants mais auquel il va
ajouter ce qu'on appelle en rhétorique
une accumulation c'est à dire qu'à la
fin il va dire Michael
il va utiliser tout un certain nombre de
synonymes pour faire monter une sorte de
tension au sein de son discours quand on
parle par slogan comme ça avec des
résonances des assonances au début et à
la fin de son propos donc Michael ceci
game cela again en rhétorique qui
s'appelle une simple c'est-à-dire quand
on a à la fois le début d'une phrase et
la fin d'une phrase qui se répète et
c'est évidemment très efficace pour
rythmer un discours donc il a toujours
jouer sur ce côté de l'homme
providentiel mais l'idée que s'il n'est
pas élu l'Amérique court à sa perte
qu'elle court à sa disparition même et
donc il y a une rhétorique
catastrophiste qui est le pendant de la
rhétorique de l'homme providentiel qui
va sauver la mairie mais je trouve aussi
que d'une certaine façon on le voit même
visuellement dans les images de ce
discours il y a peu de cris et donc on
voit pas un public chauffer à blanc
galvaniser comme on pouvait le voir par
le passé dans certains métiers de Donald
Trump et donc au total un Trump un peu
assagi